well guys the very first official pic of
Jared Leto as the Joker in the upcoming
film Suicide Squad has been released two
very mixed reactions as to be expected
now please forgive me because my voice
is not up to par I'm getting over a cold
right now and I'm going to struggle
through attempting to talk normally
because my voice is kind of like this is
the best time for me to imitate Vin
Diesel because my voice just does this
naturally right now now I'm not going to
give you that tired spiel that I myself
have said about all the weird notes to
Anam Michael Keaton and people didn't
like that tune in Heath Ledger and
you've heard it before but it is true I
mean people nitpick about everything
let's talk about the positives first for
one there are a lot of tributes to the
comics in just this one image it is
definitely honoring this iconic picture
of the Joker from the comics as well as
a Frank Miller and Gimli combination
going on with all the tats let's talk
about those tats because everyone's
freaking out about the tats you know the
Joker shouldn't have all these tats he
looks weird he looks too psychotic what
he looks too psychotic um The Joker
needs to be insane he needs to be a
psychopath looking at this picture I see
an insane man I see an insane person and
that is definitely promising to me also
speaking of those tats
I highly doubt he's gonna be shirtless
through the entire film you know he's
gonna put on his classic suit who knows
how long we'll actually see those tats
on screen now I can't quite tell if he
has fake silver teeth or if those are
just like rotting weird teeth I don't
know but if he has silver teeth I guess
that also makes sense because you know
Batman's been punching the Joker in the
mouth a lot he's gonna lose some teeth
the thing that makes a character
memorable is not necessarily his look
but the way he's written the way the
script gives him some dialogue the
storytelling the filmmaking the
performance by the actor these are
things that create a compelling
character I mean do you guys remember
when the very first picture of Heath
Ledger as the Joker was released
pretty much everyone hated it I remember
even being skeptical when I saw that
image and I just finished Marvel's
daredevil on Netflix review for that
coming very soon but I also remember
seeing the first picture of him in his
suit thinking that looks cheap as hell I
hate it this shows going to suck no
spoilers from my review but it didn't
suck I'll just say that so I'm not
really skeptical about this em
because it's just an image I do like the
fact that the Joker looks psychotic I'm
pretty sure that tats are going to be
hidden throughout the majority of the
movie but I also like the fact this
Joker has taken the time throughout his
life to tattoo things on his body that
for some reason are important to him
what I'm waiting for is to see what the
storytelling is like what the
performance is like and how well-written
his character is those are the things
that matter to make a good character
because yes Heath Ledger looks awesome
as the Joker in that makeup but if his
character wasn't written as well as he
was it wouldn't have been as compelling
these are the things I'm excited to see
and we're gonna have to wait to the
movie actually comes out but for now I
am very excited to see what Jared Leto
does as the Joker and I think this is
promising what do you guys think let me
know below and as always thank you so
much for watching guys and look forward
to my review of daredevil coming very
soon not the Ben Affleck one don't worry
as always guys thank you very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes